not standing people in numerical order
unless this is some diagonal [ __ ]
like that player profile for in which
case still bullsh what should we do
begin the next game i mean what are the
options here watch tiny people do a tiny
performance put smash bros on one of the
screens erase 212 from the very fabric
of time and space was playing the next
game ever really in question what the
[ __ ] is this guy looking at i know the
colors and artistry of the room are
captivating but there's five bodies
hanging there you're trying to figure
out if the walls are tea green or mint
also just a reminder that the game
organizers who had the foresight to
create and install a 50-foot high corpse
mobile in the escher room somehow didn't
know there was an underground organ
harvesting operation going on right
under their noses for weeks through an
impressive feat of fortune fortitude
june hoe has managed to sneak onto the
island kill a guard replace him in his
job and snuck into the head honcho's
office all without being caught i could
almost believe that if he wasn't also
texting his bestie pictures and messages
that would get this entire operation
shut down on a network that should be
constantly monitored get your parental
controls figured out before your pink
army starts doing all sorts of shady
stuff on there like googling the phrase
pinkarmy this phone rings nine times if
your phone rings more than four times
before letting me leave a message i'm
never speaking to you again
making phone calls what's wrong are you
sad i was but i've quickly moved back to
angry the more over the top and cliched
your character gets in fact i've
probably crossed over into vexed if
you're truly wanting to know for this
game you will be playing in teams of two
for an operation that just gave another
big fairness speech i'll just note that
you 100 knew you were eventually putting
them against each other and yet you say
teams of two instead of groups of two
for maximum deceit hypocrites and yes
we're hypocrites too in fact being
hypocrites ourselves makes us hypocrites
for calling you hypocrites and what was
i saying again please look around and
find someone you wish to play with oh
great now i'm having flashbacks to my
childhood all those darting eyes trying
to decide who's going to be their
partner i don't want to be the last pick
i promise i can move as fast as the ball
does pick me please mom
shake hands to show you have become
partners there can only be two players
per team force monogamy and it was adams
rip the lord used to make eve after all
and that's the reason that we're
choosing men 244 and the entire
patriarchy survives this also you've
witnessed hundreds of people murdered by
a 10-foot doll with laser eyes you've
pulled people to the death in a game of
tug-of-war and licked a sugar cookie
until it came to a satisfactory
conclusion dude there is no god you were
someone who
looked like they would come with me
title of my sex tape do you really think
you can win without me on your team
rhetorical questions he's a jerk he's
just gonna throw you under the bus 212
is going off again and no one is
stepping in to stop her for the love of
all that is nuanced and substantial
won't a single writer have a guard taper
mouse shut or something the lack of
action from these workers is being noted
in my latest escape room yelp review
[Music]
roll marbles should we do this to
make it official ah yes the holy pinky
promise the most solid of foundations
for any friendship it's nice to have
such a hopeful and wholesome episode for
once 10 marbles and we can create our
own game as interesting as this choose
your own death venture marble madness is
shouldn't there be some guidance from
the powers of the bee that encourage an
entertaining show for the audience that
may or may not be watching or exist or
not honestly we're five episodes in now
shouldn't the show of at least address
the purpose of all this just a tiny bit
so you guess if i'm holding even a rod
which one you think is in here wait
ollie has never played this game and
you're teaching him the only rule here
is no violence apparently so just tell
ali to give all his marbles to you hide
them around the room then tell them to
count for 29 minutes the first one to
find them all wins you get a one and
enjoy to fine wine by now who wouldn't
enjoy a post-murder merlot one of us is
gonna die here so it doesn't matter what
we tell each other no one can really
embarrass themselves anymore no it just
means that you spend your last 10
minutes on earth wallowing in a pit of
embarrassment after admitting to that
time you oh
that was close i almost told you about
that time i swallowed my pet goldfish
and blamed it on the cat damn it i think
he's got dementia
does that mean that he's out or he's not
gonna play so that means he forfeited
right even if that were the case what
does guihan think forfeit means does he
think the discount will riker will be
excused from this game whether gihen
realizes it or not he's trying to
convince the guard to put a bullet
number one's head some gong boo you
turned out to be
god damn it
would you please just pull yourself
together on then thanks squid game for
inspiring me to gronk spike my own
grandmother so she'll finally play call
of duty with me isn't that what i'm
supposed to learn from a scene where
gihan needs marble gandalf into a stone
wall like pizza dough to make him play
games with him sorry i find the lessons
on this show to be a bit elusive
sometimes you people said we're eagles
what is this i think we should play a
new game here huh request accepted so
this is when you choose to promote
equality not when it comes to even teams
a fair share of food or preventing a
midnight massacre but rather when a sore
loser wants to change a game to
something he thinks he'll have a better
chance of winning does equality mean
something else in this universe how do
the neon fencers even know when to
intervene are they dispensing order and
justice on their own like some sort of
salmon suited vigilantes everyone wants
to be batman but no one wants to put in
the work to be trapped in a cave full of
bats as a child oh yeah and the parents
murdered in an alley thing we take turns
throwing marbles till you make a shot
that lands in the hole i dug over there
i'm pretty good at
getting things in the holes huh if that
was meant to be a sex reference i have
many questions about how this gentleman
approaches coitus none of which i wish
to have answered go to mojito and have a
glass of maldives
really pretending everyone should know
the random movie quotes you drop into
conversation what are you people han
dope
i uh i still have one more there's one
guard per team and all they have to do
is keep track of who runs out of marbles
first and squid guard here couldn't even
manage that if this is his work ethic
then he should triangle look for another
job no
triangle look
look i'm doing my best
was that a punch replay that
yep clearly a closed fist with enough
force to move him violence is against
the rules shoot this man guard guard do
they take marble bribes
using two bullets when one could have
done the trick is a modicum of
efficiency per mortality beyond their
accountability damn
your stories are a bit too dark even for
me eli roth which one did you just say
this show man just when i think it's
gonna descend into simple battle royale
death matches it delivers the most
heartfelt nuanced morally complex
episode of the bunch centered by this
devastating moment where gehan decides
to lie to an old man to save his life
after having an in-depth conversation
about being bffs it's brilliant but it
destroys me not because i'm weak and sad
about the death and stuff just because
it's so good i have to keep giving back
these damn sin won your pouch there it's
too dangerous to keep it out these
people are bound to go crazy before the
end who knows what'll happen then we
know exactly what will happen then the
guards will step in and shoot anyone
being violent or cheating which ollie
also knows but gives over his marbles
regardless man this show is honestly
great right up until it decides to make
some characters exactly the right amount
of naive for the villain's plan to work
using your mouth to tear the t-shirt
you've been wearing through several days
of murder games without any laundering
service hole in the ground marble drop
marble blowing excitement
this marvelously convenient marble
that blue one that went in that's mine
[ __ ] i mean sure but did you agree
ahead of time about secondary contact
rules everyone here is making the ship
as they go you know because of fairness
and integrity and such here
how's that as it is with marbles so it
is with life ollie ends up dead because
he doesn't take the time to check his
sack stay safe kids and check your sack
regularly
[Music]
at this point the marbles in this bag
have all been switched out for rocks but
when he shakes that bag it makes the
distinctive noise of glass marbles
hitting each other i don't care if it's
in on the foley artist or the show argue
all you want the sin is sound there is
no guard following ali and i just spent
five minutes thinking of a better way
for ollie to use his unguarded time the
finer points are beat up a guard fake
marbles blame shifting more beating a
double-crossing fake trade all ending
with the rose-colored asses duped into
running out of bullets from inefficiency
i realized after assembling a flowchart
and storyboard that i'd rather just move
on and get to the end of this as quickly
as possible why is no one who's losing
in these games just sticking it to their
opponent by refusing to play not a
single person pulled the if i can't win
the neither of us will card let me see
darn it
i'm out of marbles what should i do huh
probably been shot by an overzealous
guard but they only seem to be actively
watching the secondary characters so i
guess you're safe for now and go meet
your mother and then make a whole show
about how it happens you could call it
how i became acquainted with your
maternal parent i bet it's a hit i'm
sipping up i'm honored that the guard
gave you this chance to say your final
words instead of just shooting you
immediately like every other losing
player they totally valued your
character moment more than consistency
logic i'd be honored too what kind of
nonsense is this makes no sense at all
direct quotes from a writer's room
argument about the logic of there only
being one battle still going on and no
other panic around the room in the final
minutes of this game somehow makes it
into the episode take it it's yours
anyway i know there was a little more to
it but this match basically ends the
same as the previous one with one player
just throwing it to the other one
couldn't gihan have won it all in a
unique way like jenga or cribbage or
exploding kittens gambu always
share everything with each other no
matter what finally an explanation for
the best man's wildly inappropriate
request at my brother's wedding
reception it's okay skip
[Music]
powerful stuff glad the show would never
undercut its impact with a story twist
later can you even imagine
[Music]
lost lost lost lost what i've lost my
marbles
everybody my hp's their pants it's the
coolest
you and me will be the best team
[Laughter]
keep thinking that having men around me
would just make me more powerful but
but i hate men now
[Applause]
sucks to be you nerd
you ever have to see anyone die before
this once we had this play go through my
town when i was a kid as time went on
more and more townsfolk got sick and
died soldiers started carrying the dead
into piles and let them on fire that's
how my grandpa grandma and older brother
all died they burned together simple yes
would have survived
[Applause]
oh why didn't you just go home that's
your home are you too good for your home
did i say that did i do that
hey
i remember my name now
my name is
my name is